it all started with a wrinkled tomato in
2015 the European Patent Office granted
a patent for a new variety of tomato
that was ideal for making ketchup it was
obtained using only biological processes
so hadn't been genetically modified the
patent got instant backlash with
campaigners accusing the EPO of
patenting life the organization then
amended its policy but the case went to
the EPO a board of Appeal the debate is
ongoing the European Parliament is
fighting to make sure that products
obtained from biological processes
aren't patentable by year the fights who
going to plants Matt Leon is the
conferral system for the innovations
craft their operation plants instituto
UN's wahlen two of them so if you deem
anita Sheffield files or plants MEP s
want farmers all across the European
Union to be able to innovate
particularly in the face of the climate
crisis breeding new types of plant
promotes genetic diversity every year
there's evolving new plant diseases and
plagues and we need the development of
new food crops that are for example
resilience to those plant disease the
center and place and if we would allow
patents and that will hamper that
innovation and that development so I
think that's very risky for the whole
world food supply Emmy P's argue that
small-scale producers are likely to be
hardest hit by these patents the
Parliament also says that allowing
companies to have patents on certain
food varieties creates a monopoly which
in turn could raise food prices across
the EU
[Music]
you